particip au marathon n'hésitez pas
derniers échauffements avant le grand
départ 620 coureurs s'étaient inscrits
pour la 10e course royale ce dimanche 5
novembre des parcours réalisés entre
Versailles et FONTENAY LE fleuri à
travers le patrimoine de ce territoire
historique pièce d'eau des Suisses
château du Roi Soleil et grand canal ces
sportifs avaient gardé un moral d'acier
pour sillonner les 10,5 km malgré une
météo capricieuse est-ce que vous sentez
prêt pour cette
course on essaye on essaye le le temps
est quand même difficile on se réchauffe
comme on peut en attendant mais hyper
motivé il a une bonne ambiance et hyper
sympa la ligne d'arrivée franchie les
sportifs laissent éclater leur joie
gadouilleux gadouilleux non mais en V il
est bien il y a quand même des bonnesg
dro par contre il est dur il y a enin il
y a quand même des montées un peu la
dernière est un peu du mais sinon ça va
cette année une particularité la course
des 20 km devient un semimarathon trajet
entre route et trail un challenge
recherché par les coureurs expérimentés
l'année dernière j'avais fait le 10 K m
et cette année le SEM euh là j'ai fait
1h 1h32 je crois 1h32 il y avait des
passages un peu difficiles avec de la
boue avec le temps les conditions
climatiques ils étaaiit pas ils étaai
pas top on va dire Johan chunet obtient
la médaille d'or sur ce circuit avec un
temps d'unh et 9 minutes récompens
supplémentaires entre 6 et 12 dossards
seront remis aux participants tirés au
sort pour prendre part au 10 km du
marathon pour tous de Paris 2024 un
moment unique pour courir dans le
sillage des futurs athlètes olympiques